en el último vídeo vimos esta propiedad
que nos dice que si una función es
constante entonces su derivada es igual
a cero y vimos para acá una explicación
gráfica de por qué sucede esto y también
utilizamos las definiciones de derivada
para estar completamente seguros de que
esta propiedad es cierta y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es ver más de estas
propiedades y estas propiedades que
estamos viendo son propiedades básicas
que vas a utilizar a lo largo de tu
carrera a lo largo de tu vida siempre
que estés utilizando cálculo vas a
utilizar constantemente estas
propiedades para encontrar derivadas así
es que es bastante importante conocerlas
y estar seguros de que si son ciertas
estas propiedades pero bueno la segunda
propiedad nos dice que si una función f
x es igual a una constante por otra
función g de x entonces
la derivada de la función f x es igual a
k la constante por la derivada de la
función g podemos explicar de forma
gráfica por qué sucede esto aquí esta
constante que está multiplicando a la
función g está modificando la pendiente
de las rectas tangentes pero
honestamente es mucho más fácil hacer un
argumento algebraico y para eso podemos
utilizar cualquiera de estas dos
definiciones de derivada
yo voy a utilizar esta definición por
acá con la equis porque me parece que se
siente más general es cierto por acá
podemos decir oye esta puede ser
cualquier valor y entonces podemos
argumentar que esta definición es igual
de general que ésta pero por el momento
me siento más cómoda utilizando esta
definición entonces si queremos
encontrar f prima de x utilizando esta
definición nosotros
que la derivada de f es igual al límite
cuando hache team de acero de f de x + h
- efe de x / h
pero a ver en este ejemplo cuánto es fx
más h
todo esto es igual al límite cuando h
tiende a cero df de x + h y eso es que
porque de x + h y luego tenemos que
restar efe de x pero efe de x es k
porque de x y estamos dividiendo esto
entre h ahora por aquí podemos
factorizar está acá y nos queda el
límite cuando h tiende a cero de acá
g de x + h - g b x / h aquí lo único que
hicimos fue factorizar esta constante k
ahora por las propiedades de los límites
nosotros sabemos que esto es igual a la
constante k
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de g de x + h
menos g de x / h y por supuesto todo
esto que tenemos aquí es simplemente que
prima de x así es que esto es igual acá
porque prima de x y ahí tengo una idea
de algo que podrías estar pensando en
estos momentos tú podrías haber dicho
oye esto parece como que sí es cierto
así es que simplemente supongamos que es
cierto pero uno no puede ir por la vida
suponiendo este tipo de cosas así nada
más es cierto una vez que empiezas a
pensar en esto parece algo muy natural
pero en las matemáticas no podemos
simplemente suponer que las cosas son
ciertas porque nos parece razonable que
sean ciertas nosotros tenemos que
demostrar que si son ciertas tenemos que
estar seguros de otra forma podemos
terminar construyendo un
donde cosas y sacando muchas
conclusiones basándonos en fundamentos
que no son sólidos pero esto que hicimos
aquí nos asegura que esto sí es cierto y
que lo podemos utilizar sin correr el
riesgo de llegar a alguna contradicción
así es que es bueno hacer todo esto
aunque parezca que estamos haciendo
mucho trabajo para llegar a una
conclusión que ya nos parecía bastante
razonable pero bueno ahora vamos a ver
la tercera propiedad la tercera
propiedad nos dice que si una función fx
es igual a la suma de otras dos
funciones por ejemplo g de x
j de x entonces s prima de x es igual a
g prima de x
j primer de equis y bueno esto también
es cierto si aquí en lugar de tener un
más tenemos un menos si en lugar de que
éstas sean sumas son restas si tienes la
suma o resta de dos funciones la
derivada va a ser la suma o resta de las
derivadas de esas dos funciones y otra
vez para asegurarnos de que esto es
cierto podemos recurrir a la definición
del límite f prima de x es igual al
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de fx + h
pero cuanto s f x más h bueno pues es
dx más h más j de x más h bueno y todo
esto es simplemente efe de x + h
todavía nos falta a restar fx y fx
tx más jota de equis porque ya que
tenemos
efe de x + h y aquí tenemos fx y
queremos dividir todo esto entre h y
aquí podemos reacomodar estos términos y
nos queda como el límite cuando h tiende
a cero deje de x + h - g de x + j de x +
h - j de x / h pero esto también lo
podemos poner de esta otra forma como
estos dos términos entre h más estos
otros dos términos entre h y estas dos
formas son exactamente iguales
esto que tenemos aquí nosotros sabemos
por las propiedades de los límites que
esto es igual al límite cuando h tiende
a 0 deje de x + h - g de x / h
+
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de j de x + h
- j de x / h ahora esto que tenemos aquí
es la definición de g prima de x y esto
que tenemos por acá es la definición de
j prima de x y listo ya terminamos la
derivada de una suma de funciones es la
suma de las derivadas ahora si en lugar
de estar sumando estuviéramos restando
por aquí tendríamos un signo menos eso
se pasaría por acá y aquí tendríamos una
resta y entonces estas derivadas
estarían restando pero bueno espero que
todo esto haya hecho que te sientas muy
seguro de que estas propiedades son
ciertas
sí es cierto tal vez podríamos haber
adivinado que son ciertas estas
propiedades pero es muy bueno utilizar
las definiciones de derivada para estar
completamente seguros de que en efecto
estas propiedades son verdaderas